en el último vídeo vimos que si tomamos
la suma esta suma desde igual a cero
empezamos en cero hasta n de los
cuadrados de y cuadrada
esto sería igual y llegamos justamente
esta fórmula un tercio de n al cubo más
un medio de n cuadrada más un sexto de n
'nos sin el sí más un sexto de n
quizá esta fórmula es válida pero quizás
no lo has visto así voy a manipular en
este vídeo esta expresión de forma
algebraica y llegar y voy a llegar a
otra que se ve típicamente en algunos
cursos y que es una forma muy bonita de
recordar esta misma misma fórmula
entonces por ejemplo qué pasa si yo soy
actor hizo un sexto de n muy bien
entonces esto sería igual a un sexto de
n y tenemos que multiplicar por algo
para que nos dé esto de acá arriba
entonces un sexto de n
porque lo tengo que multiplicar para que
me dé un tercio de n al cubo bueno un
sexto si lo multiplicamos por 2 nos da
un tercio verdad 2 entre 6 nos da 1
entre 3 y luego hay que multiplicar por
n cuadrada para que con esta n nos dé n
al cubo muy bien ahora por cuanto hay
que multiplicar un sexto de n para que
nos dé un medio de n cuadrada pues
primero hay que multiplicar por 3 si
multiplicamos por 3 nos da un medio y n
por n nos da n cuadrada finalmente hay
que sumar hay que sumar 1 para que nos
dé un sexto de n muy bien esto lo voy a
poner con rojo como estaba muy bien y
ahora lo único que nos queda es
factorizar este polinomio de aquí y lo
vamos a hacer
agrupando esencialmente lo que vamos a
hacer es descomponer el 3 en dos números
tales que su producto sea 2 por 1 que es
2 bien entonces vamos a hacerlo esto
será igual a un sexto d
por el 3 n como lo podemos descomponer
en una suma pues puede ser 2 1 verdad y
dos más uno o más bien 2 y 1 su producto
es igual que dos por uno claramente
entonces vamos a tener dos n cuadrada
n 2 n y luego sumamos 1 muy bien ahora
qué es lo que vamos a hacer seguimos con
este un sexto por n y ahora vamos a
factorizar una n de este lado entonces
vamos a tener n que multiplica a 2 n más
2 en 1 y luego esto es esta parte de
aquí ahora factor izamos 11 de este lado
y tenemos 1 x y tendremos voy a ponerlo
con los mismos colores 2n más uno
muy bien yo sé que a lo mejor esto es un
poco confuso te recomiendo que vayas a
los vídeos de factorización por
agrupando y pero bueno el detalle es que
ya tenemos un mismo factor aquí y un
mismo factor acá así que ahora podemos
factorizar este mismo y qué es lo que
nos queda nos queda un sexto de un sexto
de n que multiplica que multiplica a dos
n uno más uno
muy bien y luego esto multiplica an1n1
n 1
muy bien y ahí ya tenemos otra fórmula
para para calcular la suma de los
primeros n cuadrados muy bien y bueno la
forma más vistosa en que siempre se
presenta esto es poner n por n 1 por 2 n
1 entre 6 muy bien y que esta es una
fórmula muy sencilla de recordar o al
menos en mi caso es mucho más fácil de
recordar que esta que tenemos de todas
formas este valor que tenemos aquí es
equivalente a esta fórmula roja que es
equivalente a la suma de los primeros n
cuadrados cualquiera de estas dos
fórmulas que utilices está bien te
recomiendo que tomes la que consideres
más fácil de recordar